the jurgen experience but it crippled
the whole world
crippled the whole world crippled our
kind of that and we are the worst at it
if you look at all the other countries
no one's done a worse job
at dealing with this pandemic than us
you think it expo i think it exposed our
weaknesses
sure right our health weaknesses our
financial weaknesses
exposed a lot of our weaknesses yeah a
little little risk now and and
right like you know there's [ __ ] going
on well you know that was
there's that's like a bunch of
compounding factors right
you know you have the george floyd
murder and then you have the protests
afterwards which
ignite uh most likely is one of the
factors in the kick-up of the virus
again the second wave of it
you know there's a lot going on you know
and then also people don't like to be
told what to do here
so uh will i [ __ ] you i'm gonna go out
[ __ ] you i'm going to spring break [ __ ]
you
i'm going to florida [ __ ] you i'm not
wearing a mask i i
um we got a call i i took the approach
of we could put on a safe event
the second that i get a state or a
country that allows us to put on an
event
we're back on and we're going to put
protocols in place because
i believe i don't fight me on it if i
don't know what your thoughts are but um
i believe that you're more likely to get
like we're sitting right now
as opposed to being outside and i want
people healthy that's pretty much
established
you're more likely to get it uh inside
um
sunlight kills it and then people have
said well if sunlight kills it then the
protests
it wouldn't have spread in the protest
like not so fast you're talking about
50 000 people packed on top of each
other screaming
right the idea that the sunlight is
going to kill all of it it seems
ridiculous like and it's also going to
get into people and they're going to
bring it to their home and it's going to
get
to them they're going to go to work
they're going to give it to other people
at work or other people wherever
gatherings that they get to
whenever you get you're having like the
way uh
someone described it recently it's like
a music festival in every city
all across the country for weeks at a
time and that's what the protests were
like
i'm sure it had an impact and if you
look at the numbers
like so many of the people that have it
now are young people i think bars had a
big impact on it too
i think a lot of you know drunk talk and
bars you're right on top of each other
you're indoors
you're drinking your inhibitions are
down you're not thinking you're not
washing your hands
you're yelling you're you know you're
talking loud sloppy sloppy yeah so
so so we get a call from florida um
florida doesn't give a [ __ ] clara didn't
give a [ __ ] jacksonville
um i was definitely on the side of you
said joe what's your stance on the whole
thing my stance was
um i think we should shut down
for a period of time to get the
hospitals and our medical system
like in shape but i'm just not a
believer that you could shut down an
economy for as long as we have like it
has an eff it has some negative
consequences it's got a big negative
right like people people lose their [ __ ]
sitting indoors like forget about money
and everything else you start to lose
your mind yeah right so so um i'm
putting a race on i decide
we're shooting down there we put all the
protocols in place i'm a little annoyed
because
it's not going to be the race i'm used
to where everybody's like
like you're getting together in a
festival area and i can't have like
mud pits where we're mingling people
so i don't know how it's going to go i
drive with my family because i got to be
there if i'm
if i'm the leader of this organ i got to
be there driving my family down
the east coast when i get to south
carolina
there's no virus there's not there's
like
corn dogs and partying and like beaches
full of
all the way to florida there was no it
was completely different than new york
and everywhere else like it was game on
so it's not shocking that um the virus
is huge down there yes
to the fire itself you know they said
florida if it was a country would be the
fourth highest rate of infection in the
entire world
i i gotta tell you and i'm not
self-serving we put on a good
safe event really good event and so far
that knock on wood
no issues but like there was no
protection no protocol nothing down in
the states down there do you
uh impose uh tests on the we did tests
all
all of our employees we we tested with
the uh swap that you know touches you
touches your brain with the swab unlike
your your rusty knife on my hand
did you do temperature checks and they
did temperature checks with everybody we
kept everybody distance
i'm not i'm not just saying it because
like my team went overboard
right it was annoying to me at how at
how good they did it
and can't make money like that because i
can't i can't get enough people
in the event to right i got to space
them out and
how many people did you know normally
we'd have 8 000 at that event called a
couple of thousand so i can't i can't
make those numbers work but i thought it
was important
because there's 50 000 events around the
world that are shut down new york
marathon boston go down the list
and if we could provide like a path to
hey this could be done
it was important to do but it's not 50
000 events have been shut down
50 000 around the world that crazy wow
we're we are the hardest hit industry
because we're not like a restaurant
where i could deliver food
like i'm dead right i'm dead i'm out of
business right right
i got to keep paying people but so
how many events do you normally run a
year 325 45 countries
325 events and i'm down i'll be lucky
i'll be lucky if we have 20 this year 20
from 325.
so 305 down down tough year
[Applause]